this new aircraft carrier will revive
the UK's ability to launch jets from the
sea by 2021
but even before this long-awaited moment
to defense sources claim senior Royal
Air Force officers are seeking to reduce
the number of f-35 warplanes that can
operate from its deck to free up cash
for the so called a variant of the jet
that can only fly from land in a sign of
their anger one agreed to speak on
camera if we concealed his identity what
would be the actual impact like why
should people care what people don't
understand is the potential damage this
will do to us UK relations the u.s.
regard the Royal Navy is the one and
only peer Navy able to operate aircraft
carriers but if the British turn up to
an operational theater without combat
aircraft it will completely undermine
their military capability to the US this
is a really big deal if the RAF go for
the a variant of the expense of the
carriers this will be perceived by the
US as a major betrayal he accused some
in the RAF of wanting to fly f-35s from
air bases more than from HMS Queen
Elizabeth and a second new carrier the
rau is over two different types of the
f-35 lightning too fast jet the a model
which officially costs 70 million pounds
and can only fly from land and the B
model priced at 90 million pounds which
can also operate from carriers Britain
says it aims to buy a total of a hundred
and thirty eight of the Jets starting
with forty-eight by 2025 of the B
version the two defense sources accused
members of the RAF of privately trying
to convince defense secretary Gavin
Williamson to swap in some of the land
base variant even into the initial
purchase of 48 aircraft saying the Jets
of Cheaper fly further and carry more
weapons but they can't fly off carriers
it is an absolute disgrace and it should
not be allowed to happen and it has to
be stopped here and it has to be stopped
now
with money tight if you believe Britain
will ever buy all 138 Jets of either
type the Ministry of Defence tonight
insisted the land variant would not be
among the first 48 aircraft purchased
though one insider said the idea of
swapping in A's had been informally
raised the two defense sources say
they're not convinced by the official
assurance and with up to another 90 Jets
yet to be agreed on they say they'll
certainly be more battles ahead there
behind Sky News